if we talk about the women yeah i
actually think like
there's a difference in the way there's
a fundamental difference in the way
that men and women view god
and
that's why there's so many women in the
church this is my hypothesis right
so women are attracted to powerful men
and god is the most powerful man
that's why you're here
that's interesting and that is why
you'll hear women say ah i don't need a
man i've got jesus
you've heard women i've heard women say
that you know what and it's like i don't
i don't hear men say that men don't say
oh i'm i'm all right i don't need a wife
i've got jesus it's like that's the yeah
yeah but that's like that's my theory
like my theory is we have a fundamental
difference whether it's consciously or
subconsciously in the way in which we
view god because god is the most
powerful man and women are attracted to
powerful men so here's my question
though so i'm attracted to jesus
i don't know i don't know the inner
workings of the psychology around it but
so here's what here's my question though
because is it that they're going to god
or is it that they're going to the
church
um i think a bit of both i think church
is like
it's a communal setting isn't it it's
like people
like to be around a certain community
yeah and i think it gives them that
sense of belonging to a community of
some kind but i do think
yeah i just think that it's different
and i also think like
see the last girl that i was seeing like
seriously
she was very heavily christian
and i'm not
anymore like i grew up but i'm really
not religious anymore and um
it was interesting because
when we were like together she was like
oh i don't know if this is correct i
don't know if this is right i think you
know
you should become a christian and i was
like no that's not gonna happen
um
she was like well i don't know if this
is right and i'm like
well look
we're in this we love each other like
what's the problem and she was like i
have to go and speak to my pastor right
and so i was just like okay
um
i'm not happy with that but if that's
what you feel like you need to do and
then she came back and she was like yeah
i don't think we can be together
and i was like isn't that interesting i
said yup that's a deposit must be your
man then
she was like what do you mean i said
because any man that can talk to you and
tell you not to believe me must be a man
i'm clearly not him
do you know what i mean so i said go be
your man and she was like
oh it's not like that i said listen no
no no no no because if i went away and i
said oh i'm going to go and talk to
serena yeah and i came back from talking
to serena and i was at babe i don't
think we could be together who the [ __ ]
is that [ __ ]
and a lot of women like they idolize the
pastors in these churches you know what
i mean like
like they idolize the pastor so the
pastors have so much power like he's the
closest one to god of everyone right
exactly do you think that's why i think
it's completely different man i'll be
honest i think it's more
i think
i think a big reason why pastors today
are idolized a lot
by
single women is because
he tells them that god is going to bring
them my husband
so all they have to do is wait
and if anybody knows anything about life
you can't just sit in your ass waiting
for things to come to you right so it
kind of removes the responsibility
of having to
uh either put yourself out there or make
the effort or put yourself in an
environment
where
someone can come to you
right
um and i also think part of the reason
like i said about
about uh you know
i like the internet i like the idea of
god's the most powerful man you know
um
but again i think it's more because
i just know a few older women who use
the whole oh but i've got jesus as
as an excuse not to feel
lonely yeah
it's like you know if all their friends
have kids and they're married and stuff
and then she's the only one single just
like oh like what's happened she's like
no i've got jesus right
and the thing is because it's like a
religious sentiment it's hard for
anybody like jesus ain't hugging you at
nighttime you're not gonna argue with
that yeah
do you know what i mean but that's just
my thoughts don't you think it's them
arguing with themselves
yeah low key it's like
they they say not about jesus but just i
feel like they're thrown at you as you
said because they know it's a sensitive
thing yeah they're not they just throw
it so
other people can't be like to them all
yeah because you can have jesus and have
a man
because you can you can have both you
can but so
exactly that's that's really my point
yeah that's really my point but the
church sorry
i was going to ask you the girl that
like broke it off with you because you
weren't christian were you hooking up
with her
yeah to some degree yeah yeah so like
isn't that
like she go ask her pastor about that
i mean
that was
the point of contention yeah yeah that
she like how old was she she's like 30
33 oh gosh yeah
so it's like
that was a point of contention because
she felt guilty about it do you know
what i mean and i'm like
i feel guilty that very love
do what we want you know what i mean
but um yeah it was she had a stronger
sense
i guess or a stronger feeling towards
you know the church and her religion and
stuff which is you know it's cool it's
just like a very interesting experience
for me to go through like oh [ __ ] like
jesus cop blocked me do you know what i
mean
what
oh
you saved you oh you said you never know
you never know it's true you never know
you never know it wasn't my it was not
my portion
have you